martin petit je parle en plein grand
montréal comique
c'était un festival qui est écrit dans
la foulée de la foire aux aux deux ans
plus tard à ce que les choses vont mieux
animaux je pense et j'espère que les
changements définitivement nous autres
on le sait le climat le climat est le
fun puis les choses vont je pense vont
mieux je pense que je regarde pas
l'avenir je pense que ouais je pense que
ça augure bien pour l'avenir
j'ai jamais j'ai 2 go mais si j'avais
deux fiches projets répondent pas que
mes filles face de nous on est partis du
grand montréal comédie feist ou grand
montréal que les changements dont un an
seulement qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il a fallu trouver un nom à une
soirée parce qu'ils aient quand tu pars
un projet mais on s'est aussi rendu
compte qu'il faut que tu réserves des
sites internet avant même à paris parce
que sinon il ya du monde qui réserve sa
peau est ici on n'a pas pu s'installer
autour d'une table puis demander à des
jeunes commençaient enquête ipsos on a
créé ce vite le feedback steak 1 - votre
nom son épingle of ages parfois on va le
changer
donnez nous du temps on le change à noël
puis puis je pense que c'est à l'image
du festival d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
changé de troisième fois medal sens où
on est allé coûte déjà c'est pas du
cinoche d'importance pas le logo c'est
l'expérience convient puis on a déjà des
idées pour l'un trois fois qu'on est à
bali ce jeu parce que les quelque chose
de fou l'appui de deux cloches le fait
d'être entre les créatures deux joueurs
de mo mais surtout deux gars sur le
chômage
le grand montréal communis une gamme de
création vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux en humour et depuis vos débuts
avec les bizarroïdes avec ken scott
j'appuie nombreux est-ce que c'est plus
difficile à faire sa marque en aurait
déjà sa place
ben j'imagine que pour quelqu'un qui est
dans la relève instrument politique
commenté qui commence en humour sont
effectivement sur un dans un domaine qui
est balisé puis il ya des gars qui ont
dit qu'ils ont des spécialités
c'est peut-être port c'est peut-être
plus facile quand manger comment fait
tout à fait je pense que quand on est
conscient de tout ce qu'ils ont la
chance comme moi peut-être dès dimanche
la relève mais c'est à nous autres de le
faire de les aider parce que après les
pêcheurs vovo n'est qu'un autre
spectacle pyromane d'abord et vous
voulez parler de censure
ben entre audois dans l'air du temps il
ya toujours en fait c'est toujours un
petit parfum de censure je réalise à
toutes les fois toutes les époques mais
ça vient jamais dès maintenant en droit
puis on dirait que c'est toujours les
humoristes on est toujours à la première
ligne de front deux cahiers de la
censure ben c'est tout à des humoristes
qui sont visées pour nous poser
certaines choses pour traiter de ce
sujet ça fait partie et on dirait que du
quotidien d'un humoriste de constamment
se faire dire de pause et puis moi j'ai
un très mauvais rapport que l'autorité
je pense que toutes les humoristes
si on il gobe de monter sur scène parce
qu'on a de la misère à ce pas dit non
mais on à lanzarote l'autorité je suis
moi ça a marqué ma jeunesse mon rapport
le comité après que je ne pense pas dit
que je peux pas dire quelque chose
enfin qui s'occupent d'un enfant c'est
plus facile parce qu'un cerveau et 4% si
j'ai un cerveau
j'ai étudié la danse c'est
multifonctionnel en tant qu'humoriste
lorsque vous voyez tout ce qui s'est
passé
mac world les polémiques sur twitter
bean en appel
est-ce que parfois il ya le danger de
l'autocensure des juges et je pense sur
les jo que tu fais puis en vieillissant
je vous raconte dans mon métier que tu
es aussi jugé sur les jo que tu fais pas
ça qu'il dit à mener il faut savoir que
ce doc ne faut pas la faire même si
c'est un défaut la place tandis que les
marchés de ce qui s'est passé n'était
pas trouvée mais je sais pas trop
regarder comment t'as fait pas remarquer
qui secoue les nabots est dans votre
série à succès les pêcheurs cinq saisons
où vous êtes sans sourire à quelques
reprises entre autres en 2014
vous avez carrément camp d un sketch un
épisode
pourquoi comment fait ses choix le frère
gerry
un épisode parce que l attentat de
charlie hebdo l'histoire c'est un
humoriste puis il y avait une tuerie
puis avec quelqu'un qui rentre caschili
l'humoriste était confronté à ça ça ça
ressemblait beaucoup à ce qui est arrivé
à charlie hebdo qui ont les écrire un
mois 20 puis on avait eu des discussions
puis je me rappelle quelqu'un qui me dit
c'est de tout et épisodes c'est
peut-être le plus tiré par les cheveux
parce que je voulais pas que ça va
arriver puis un mois après il ya eu la
tête de charlie hebdo plomb on sait
toutes appelé pour me fait bon mais on
un épisode qui sait qu'ils aient que ça
allait arriver dans le fond ça qu'on
leur ai écrit petit jeu les justes écrit
je l' ai sauvé c'est devenu d'autres
choses mais détesté par cancer est un
petit merci beaucoup merci recherchons
une boîte à lunch un ah oui je pensais
d'une subaru multi grèce veut savoir